so now that we had the dream solution
and we all decided it's best we move to
pure typing right that's right for your
typing is a wonderful way to test your
ideas in fact we want to make prototypes
that they're real enough to feel so that
we can test them with users and that's
all that's required prototyping can take
many forms the simplest is to do a paper
prototype where you can quickly gather
feedback one level up from that is to
work on digital designs that are made
fidelity or high fidelity the higher the
fidelity the easier it is to test and
get feedback from users because they're
looking at something that's a little bit
more polished a next level of
prototyping is actually creating
physical prototypes when you work on
something like Project Glass at Google X
or Project loon it's not about software
always it's about what does the physical
the physical device look like so that's
when it's useful to have materials that
help you create a quick shape of a
general of a general idea other
prototypes that we have made include
video in fact if you're trying to
explain the product to someone creating
a video is super super useful yeah
Dropbox that that that's right
the little how-to videos that a lot of
companies use to describe their services
are really useful in the design phase if
you make it straight on even if it's
shot with a little mobile phone and the
users are the friends that you're
working with that can be sufficient to
explain the idea to a user or to an
investor and to test it if you want the
high quality prototype you need to spend
longer developing it so I can actually
code it that's right I think coding a
prototype is a great idea so some people
are able to really sprint and within two
days start to already code the prototype
and then you can have an interactive
demo or some people take maybe four or
five days depending on how complex the
solution is so the duration of the
prototyping phase is usually what
determines the duration of the Sprint
this is the key aspect in which actually
the work is getting made
if you're someone who loves to code who
loves to design this
this is kind of like the face that you
really have to shine and if you're
looking for a low fidelity prototype a
short sprint a few hours might be
sufficient if you want something the
trifle with you requires a demo or a
video
you're better advice to have a whole
week of the games time so you can make
something beautiful how do I know which
to choose if I choose a high fidelity or
low fidelity what is the best okay so if
you're working the new product it's
probably best suited for medium fidelity
that means that you're not looking at
paper prototypes necessarily you might
have some early wireframes and that
you're starting to put some color on
them or did you also use keynote or a
quick prototyping tool that your
engineers know how to use in order to
bring some life to the ideas we believe
in teams choosing their own their own
prototyping tools there's a lot that are
available in the market and the right
ones are the ones that your team loves
to use if you're wondering where to
start
sketch is a really great example so is
the Dobby suite although it does take a
little bit of time to learn and then
keynote and Google Sites are also really
useful in prototyping quickly